here are this week's top movies haven't  you ever wanted something more you  should be serving your country lucien  based on a true story american-made  follows a pilot recruited by the CIA to  run a covert operation oh this is legal  if you're doing up for the good guys I  would like you to stop my heart you give  it one minute and then you bring me back  in Flatliners five medical students  discover that the afterlife is far more  frightening than they ever could have  imagined in Victoria and Abdul British  Queen Victoria finds unexpected  friendship the young Indian clerk see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  fantasy patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]